hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round eleven of
the 2013 candidates tournament now I
don't know how many of you remember from
my towel versus botanique series there
was this the one game where where Tull
mentions how it's very different to play
a match and it's very different to play
a tournament when you play a match you
face the same opponent over and over and
over and over and when you play a
tournament you have okay I'm probably
gonna win against these two I'm gonna
draw against these two and you know it's
it's okay to lose maybe against these
two and you know you sort things out in
your head and I think something like
this is what happened in this game but
you'll see the game and you will be able
to decide for yourselves it's a very
interesting game and it's a really
really sharp position which you can
pretty much always expect when 11 our
engine is playing in a very strong
tournaments such as the candidates and
before we actually see the game we do
have some photos now here we have a nice
close-up of Peter Svidler writing down
some information before the game starts
another nice close-up of Levin around
not really a close-up more of a well he
just arrived at the board didn't even
sit down just yet then we have well this
is a very nice close-up again of LaVon
Aragon pretty much every photo of Leven
origin when he's just you know thinking
before the game starts is pretty much
the same but always enjoyable and here a
very funny photo here you can see a
photo of the audience who actually came
there to watch this event alive but
they're not really watching it live they
are there but they have like very small
tablets and the end earphones so even
though they are they're alive you know
they have like smaller screens then I
have I have a 24 inch screen and when I
watched chess tournament you know I'm
really enjoying it I have actually two
screens because I need them for work so
on on one screen I have the commentators
on the other screen I have the board but
you know the people who actually came
there to watch it live they're actually
having I don't know less less of it then
you're getting at home but but at least
they can watch the players you know in
real time so it's a you know you did
to watch it live but you're not really
watching your life so it's it's very
funny that way and let's just have a
quick glimpse this is this is a the
tournament standings after round 10 so
as you can see 11 Aragon is in second
place with six and a half points he's up
against Peter Svidler would four and a
half points so I win for Spiller would
definitely mean a lot for the standings
and I went for our Anyang could could
also you know wrap up that that first
place for him even though there are a
couple more rounds till the end of the
tournament but every point counts now so
let's see the game
Sweetwater is white and he opens with d4
we have a knife to f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 we have the
nimzo-indian defense a3 and Bishop
captures on c3 we have pawn captures on
c3 and now c5 if you remember also since
we already mentioned the talbot unix
series stall did try nice to e4 he
prepared this and after Queen c2 then f5
was the idea Talon Koblenz prepared from
the mark mark time on a book but you
know theory advanced a long way since
then and now c5 the cemetery ation by 11
Aragon now we have III Queen to a5
attacking the c3 pawn bishop to d2
defending and only now 9 3 4 as a black
already gave up the bishop pair now he
wants to deprive white of the bishop
pair Bishop to d3 Knight captures Queen
captures and d6 we have f4 Knight to d7
and the knight to f3 now f5 and now
castling seems like an automatic here
but it seems that fiddler is very well
prepared and he plays d4 which is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
so he is still in home preparation but
as usual you are always welcome to check
out the interview after this game it
will be and there will be a link in the
description below you know you know
everything
so f captures only for Bishop captures
on e4 and now Knight to f6 attacking the
bishop bishop back to c2 and now again
it seems like black can freely castle
here which you can but Bishop to d7
Aragon has a different plan
we have castles C capture some before
and now
what do you do you could untie your
pawns see capture some before definitely
you know seems like something you should
do but if you do this then like can
immediately exchange Queens and what did
you really achieve as white in the
opening nothing much and you know you
are in the lower half of the standings
and it's already around eleven you don't
want to waste a game with the white
pieces like this
so after C captures only four Queen
captures on the force wheeler is kind of
not allowing RN and the castle as he
does have to deal with the threat of
Queen captures and v6 but Erin and says
no not really
and he castles anyway so Queen captures
on d6 Queen captures on c3 now a d6 pawn
seems much juicier than the CC pawn but
okay Bishop to d3 and now attacking
defending the c4 pawn rook to d8 and
rook to c1 would an attack on the Queen
Queen to a5 we have 90 to e5 and Bishop
to c8 opening up a discovered attack
from the rook to the Queen and Queen to
b4 and this is the critical moment of
the game what do you do here Spiller
offers a trade of Queens of course he
wants Aragon to accept this after he
accepts then a capture some before he
fixes his pawn structure and but the
problem is after something like Knight
to d7 as this is you know this Knight is
to actively have to do something about
this
Knight here preparing to capture and
remove the defender of the bishop on d3
so rush up to e4
you don't want to you know any funny
business here so after Knight captures
pawn captures rook capture screen
captures you've exchanged a lot of
pieces here and the problem is white
will be better here because you do have
this completely undeveloped the bishop
on c8 and it's very hard to develop this
bishop let's say rook to d4 attack the
bishop here still Bishop to f3 and now
you still there's really no way to
develop the bishop here the b7 pawn is
under attack and if you play something
like this you have to waste a lot of
time then King comes into the play after
you try something like better place X
then you simply kick the bishop back
Bishop has to retreat all the way to see
it then you move further you attack the
rook King III after rook goes
back then Bishop to c6 you can you gain
so much space and the black always has
to be careful rook to it one is coming
and if you're not if you try to defend
this would work too afraid to f7 then
white can infiltrate using the D file
it's a very it's a very hard position
for black to play probably white will
we'll win this so after Queen to b4
there are none place between to c7 and
if you will be interested in an
interview after the game
Aragon played Queen to c7 and you know
he he specifically planned his next move
which is a which is a real chaotic move
we have c5 and now comes g5 so this is
the move you will not see very often
especially not in a very strong
tournament like this you might see it in
a bullet or a hyper bullet game but in a
candidate's tournament the engine really
I mean it's not like the engine doesn't
like this move it's just it's nowhere
nowhere in the recommended ideas but
over the board you know it's something
Oregon will always always play and you
have to be ready for this so how do you
how do you counter this the engine will
counter it with g3 but over the board
you know the clock is ticking you have
to make something happen you know who's
really gonna play g3 so Wheeler goes for
the active idea
he plays c6 c six is it's kind of a kind
of a blunder
because ninth to d5 can can stabilize
over everything for black now the Queen
on b4 is under attack you have to do
something here after bone capture some
b7 Queen captures Queen captures Bishop
captures F captors on g5 but now Knight
to f4 and the knight is now attacking
the bishop on d3 the bishop is attacked
twice the knight and the bishop are both
attacking the g2 pawn so white will be
up on but only temporarily black black
equalised this so c6 not the most
precise idea but you know countering an
imprecise idea with another imprecise
idea always a good idea B 5 B 5 a move
that again doesn't really it doesn't
really help our engines plan
you could capture the pond that's true
Queen captures Bishop captures is an
idea but fiddler is isn't interested in
the point he plays Queen to e1 g5
weakens the King and now it's time to
bring all of the forces over to the King
side Queen to g3 will be an idea rook to
d5 and now comes Queen to g3 h6
but h6 doesn't really doesn't really
help black all that much F captures on
g5 we have Queen captures on e5 Queen
captures and e5 rook captures and now
pawn captures on f6 King to f7 we have
rook to f4 rook to d8 attacking the
bishop on d3 Bishop to e4
so rook to f4 a very nice move rook to
f4 was preparing Bishop to f4 and from E
for Bishop to b4 and from E for the
bishop will very nicely limit the
movement of this rock on e5 and also
defend the pawn on c6 so rook to the 8th
now bush of 24 as planned and rook to d2
a very active move for black but not not
active enough as as you'll see in the
game h4 we have a 5 rope the c3 rook to
e2 and now comes now comes a wonderful
move by Svidler feel free feel free to
pause the video and find the move here I
mean there are draw more actually more
move you can play but this one is you
know it really shows black who's boss
so photos we found that congratulations
you you know you you have just beaten 11
onion and for those of you who just want
to enjoy it show Bishop to g6 with check
is an idea which was played in the game
now of course if King captures then f7
there is no stopping the pond from
queening so after Bishop to g6 check
King to f8 was played now comes a rook
to d4 already sweedler is threatening
rook to d8 checkmate we have looked to
d5 rook captures pawn captures and now
rope the c5 attacking both the b5 1 and
the d5 point we have rook e1 check King
h2 and now rook to f1 attacking the f6
pawn f7 now
we have before captures captures and now
rook captures on d5 so white is up two
points and there's really not all that
much black can do here we have King to
g7 and now once again you're free to
pause the video here and find the
winning idea how do you win this game so
it's there there is one move you can
make which ends the game immediately as
feeler made that and after that move
around resigned the game so feel free to
posit to find the move you know yeah I
mean you can win this position a lot of
times but it you know it's always best
to finish the game in the strongest way
possible so for those of you who found
it
congratulations you are once again an
excellent endgame player and for those
who just won in show rope to d8 was
played and in this position 11 are
resigned the game why did you resign
well of course you cannot capture the
bishop if you play keen captures then
you get f8 Queen and then simply the
rook will be stronger than Bishop better
up three six let's say rook attacks pawn
only three now comes c7 you do have
another pass pawn and whatever black
plays you will simply capture it if
Bishop captures then you bring a queen
into the game so nothing really to do
here and on the other hand after rope to
d8 even if you don't capture let's say
try b3 then comes Rock to g8 check even
worse after after King f6 now you bring
another Queen into the game and after
King to e6 you can choose whatever you
want you can capture Bishop you can
capture the rope you can checkmate the
black King if you like you know
whichever you prefer you know I always
prefer to go for checkmate but some
people some people will you know try to
humiliate your opponent to be if your
opponent doesn't want to resign so maybe
you wanna you know gobble up all of his
pieces and only then win the game either
way I have to rope the d8 are and resign
the game so yeah a great game and a
great story behind the game it's you
know it's a shame for 11-hour and he was
in second place now he took a pretty
hard blow but an excellent shot for
Peter Svidler to take a take you know he
is shot at the first place in this
tournament
so yeah now once again I do hope you
enjoyed it pretty sure Oregon did not
but you know it's just and yeah that's
it
I think all for watching as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
Sierra think of for watching once again
and I will see you soon with one more
game from round 11 of the 2013
candidates tournament and then we're
gonna check out the standings and talk
about the tournament some more so see
you soon